it's been about a week now of demon
slaying Diablo 3 ultimate evil edition
but I have a few tips to help you
continue the good fight in sanctuary
first and foremost make sure you have
elective mode turned on if you didn't
notice this it's actually a pretty
important feature that isn't turned on
by default elective mode allows you to
use multiple skills from the same skill
tree without it on you are only allowed
to pick one skill from each tree however
with elective mode you can pick as many
as you want so make sure you go into the
options and turn this on my next tip is
to make sure to take full advantage of
the massacre bonus the trap bonus and
the destructible bonus I'm sure you've
noticed that fuse in the middle of the
screen but make sure to maintain your
Massacre bonuses for as long as you can
to get the biggest experience bonus
multiplier possible the more monsters
you kill will equate to more experience
for you and your teammates once you've
reached about 150 to 200 monsters killed
the experience bonus will however cap
out in addition make sure you try to
kill as many monsters as you can with
traps as not only does it instantly kill
monsters but it gives you a sweet trap
bonus that will help you regenerate
resources at double the rate lastly try
to smash has many destructible items in
succession as possible to get the
destructible bonus which will give you a
speed bonus that will increase your
movement speed dramatically the more
objects you break the longer the buff
will last tip number 3 is how to become
the best bounty hunter you can be best
way for farming bounty bags and rift
Keystone's is to do them as fast as you
can even if it's on Normal difficulty a
way to speed up farming bounties is to
join a group online and split farm them
you and up to three other party members
can each do a bounty alone to get the
bounty bags done faster you will only be
able to do this in multiplayer though
and not on local land once you've
finished an entire axe bounties you will
receive a bounty bag reward the bounty
bags had the potential dropping you
random Legendary's but more importantly
they can drop act specific bounty
legendaries these legendary items can be
very powerful such as the royal ring of
grandeur which allows you to wear one
less set item to achieve the next set
bonus the bounty bag specific legendary
drop rates do not vary by difficulty
hence why I recommend doing them on
normal or whatever difficulty you can do
them
yet my final tip is how to become a
better gambler weapons amulets and rings
cost more than every other piece of gear
that you can gamble on choose your most
pressing need and try to gamble for
legendaries that will help bolster those
specific slots after you've gambled
through the pieces that costs 5 shards
move on to rings weapons and amulets
keep an eye out on plus elemental damage
percentage as it will greatly increase
your damage output but not actually show
up on your DPS charts these are just
some tips to help you with your long
lasting struggle and sanctuary slay
those monsters and become a true hero
you